great thanks so much for the nice intro
and and for inviting me
um and thank everyone for for attending
uh hopefully we'll all see each other in
person before too long
so i want to tell you about um
a little bit of work i've done about how
quantum
and classical computers can can work
together to solve problems
and uh this partly was
was motivated by my thoughts about
many quantum algorithms are designed
with input models that are not always
the most
directly related to problems so actually
umesh mentioned the linear system of
equations algorithm
and i've spent a lot of time since i'm
thinking about how you might use it
and what are the barriers to using it or
the the challenges you know what
what additional things need to be solved
in order to use it
and it caused me to realize that that we
should be thinking about quantum
algorithms it's a very
important detail um is to organize them
by the type of input
so we often think about classical
algorithms as having
what you might call the standard input
model so the input is it
is a string you know written on the tape
of a touring machine or on a hard drive
or in ram
and the output could be a bit or it
could be a string not much difference
and a lot of the sort of the cleanest
estate problems are often in this model
like factoring you know we all kind of
agree on how the input is
is described and how the output is
described and uh
you know it's all very satisfactory
commentorial optimization like a
three-sat instance
you want to you know you want to uh
satisfy as many clauses as you can in
the three set instance we all agree how
the instance is written down
what the answer looks like okay maybe
this is quite hard to solve but at least
uh
you know maybe we can talk about some
approximation algorithms to it uh
at least the the input and output is is
quite clear
um but to design quantum algorithms we
often want to work with
other models this is often a very
intellectually fruitful thing to do for
example
the oracle model maybe the input x1
through xn
where our access to it is not of a
string written down but we have
implicit access to it given by way of a
subroutine or an
oracle that we can query in
superposition and this is the way that
grover is defined
uh the nand tree problem the collision
speed up
as well as exponential speedups like the
hidden subgroup problem and the welded
tree problem
uh and sometimes these overlap so
one thing that shore did what he showed
or rather this kittav's version of it
showed how the hidden sub problem over a
billion groups could be solved
efficiently
this is an abstract problem that doesn't
tell you what the black box function is
it just says suppose you have a black
box function
that you can compute that has this
particular kind of symmetry
then a quantum computer can find the
hidden subgroup
it takes additional work to go from that
to uh to a factoring algorithm
so the hsp sorry is useful by itself but
but not uh not immediately sufficient
and then there are other ones that are
uh another direction we can go on on a
quantum computer
is we can say the input can be given as
quantum data so this is what happens for
the linear systems algorithm if the
input is given as a quantum vector and
this is
what enables the big speedups um the
fourier transform is another story you
have a classical and a quantum fourier
transform
and they are incomparable because they
operate on different types of data right
the classical fourier transform
operates on a list of numbers that you
might have in ram the quantum fourier
transform operates on the amplitudes
of a wave function uh neither one is a
substitute for the other right
they're really achieving different
things and there are many algorithms in
this nation of this intro that are very
useful uh but often useful as
subroutines right the quantum fourier
transform
doesn't solve the problem by itself it's
an element in these other things like
like factoring
and finally the most uh you can combine
the quantum data and the oracle model to
get the quantum oracle model
where you're given black box assets and
unitary u this this too can be useful
um but you you know you can tell a
pattern here
often times this is part of a subroutine
that we'd like to use
building towards something in the
standard model where we have a
conventional input and a
and a conventional output um in fact all
these show up in factoring right so
phase estimation is something in the
quantum oracle model the quantum fourier
transform
something the quantum data model hidden
sub problem is in the oracle model
you know all of those are different
ingredients that that sure combined
to to achieve factoring all of them are
intellectually great accomplishments on
their own
um but to make them useful you you want
to go a little bit further
so uh let's wrong way um
so what about grover's algorithm this is
one of the most basic earliest
algorithms
you can explain it very simply it's a
beautiful
um picture of of what you can do with
the quad computer it's beautiful because
it's like you know it's client like
climbing a smooth wall there's just
nothing for the algorithm to grab onto
and yet you can go from classical end to
quantum root n
and the original title of the paper was
confusingly titled a quantum mechanical
algorithm for database search
and somewhere between the archive and
pra this got changed but
it's super confusing because there's
really nothing to do with databases it
really is
if i have a function that i can compute
and the truth table of that function
f you know f of one through f of n
corresponds to my bit string
then i can find uh a marked element
in that implicit database of function
outputs
and and that is
you know that's i think the right way to
think about grover's algorithm
and since then of course we found many
similar quadratic or
or polynomial speedups for many other
unstructured or semi-structured search
problems like maximizing
a black box function approximately
counting uh you know like adding up
integration
et cetera finding collisions finding
triangles and graphs
game trees are like man trees um we can
speed up
um simulated annealing roughly
quadratically
so many things don't rely on very much
structure the problem we can get these
kind of quadratic speed ups
um but it involves an oracle right this
oracle is a subroutine
that that takes in uh an index that you
want to query and returns
x sub i and if this is a picture of a of
a data center
um that is not something that you know
that is not the same as an oracle we
cannot query the data center in
superposition you
you cannot use grover's algorithm to to
search the data center
nor would you want to right if you
wanted to just find a record in your
data center that match some criteria
um you should probably um
well if you're not building an index you
should probably do it in parallel or if
you have a gazillion hard drives
you probably have a gazillion over four
cpus
and so you could just distribute your
query to all of those
um and uh and that would make more sense
than doing some kind of sequential
search
um now one
proposal for getting grover to work on
um on a large data set is to
um is to build a quantum ram
um but you know as a theorist i would be
a little embarrassed to do this because
my job is already easier i see some
experimentalists on the call
i already have a job that is way easier
than the experimentalist job
and i think you know for me to
merely ask the experimentalists to build
a conventional
quantum computer with a million error
corrected qubits
um i want to just limit my demands to
that and not ask them for any kind of
additional hardware requirements at
least not until i've done a little bit
more work
on the algorithm theory side so i think
a quantum ram would be great
but as theorist i have some obligation
to see what i can do without it
okay so what what can i do without it um
let's suppose that
i have my input x1 through xn
it lives on on one of these kinds of
devices i guess it's already
a little bit of an old-fashioned kind of
hard drive and i want to turn it into a
quantum oracle i'm still looking for a
good illustration for that if anyone has
ideas let me know
um how can i do it um it's not so easy
one answer which is somewhat
unsatisfactory
is if i have a quantum computer which is
um since i i see dan here it's a it's
going to be an
uh an ion trap computer um i've got a
bunch of ions
they're getting blasted by lasers or
maybe there's some magnetic fields that
are changed
these are controlled by the pulse
generator which talks to the fpga
which talks to the laptop which maybe is
connected to the hard drive
so what the laptop can do is read the
hard drive read one record
figure out what x sub one is figure out
a bunch of quantum
gates that will perform this controlled
operation
if this first register is one then add x
sub one to the second register that's
unitary
and just do that n times sequentially so
the quantum computer
never has to directly touch the hard
drive right there's no
weird data model here it's a completely
conventional
kind of data model um and uh
could work for a very small quantum
computer and a large hard drive
it works but there's a terrible cost to
it which is this order n
cost right so if i have to do an order n
if every single query to my database
takes time order n
that's going to wipe out the speed up
for a lot of oracle problems
so what can i do well i can posit the
existence of a qram
which you know that solves some problem
but creates others
um or i can do what peter shore did i
can say
well this x1 through xn i just need to
come up with a
efficiently calculable function so short
came up with modular exponentiation
f of i is a to the i mod n if you can
come up with that function
and realize that solving the hidden
subgroup problem there solve your
problem
then that's great uh but as we've seen
in the in the 25 years since shore's
algorithm
those insights do not come along every
year and and certainly they don't apply
to every data set right some
some data sets correspond to the truth
tables of efficiently calculable
functions
some of them are just you know a big
pile of cat images you have from the
internet
and there's no reason to assume that
such a function exists or if it did how
you'd ever find it
um so instead
um although there is actually a
possibility
of trying to use some sort of generative
model to create such a function and i
think there's uh
there's definitely room for progress
there um
which is uh yeah which is i think
another possible direction to take this
work in
um what i'm going to talk about are ways
that
we can reduce the size of the data set
and and still get a meaningful speed up
so i'll talk about problems that are uh
fairly
natural problems like clustering
bayesian inference
and saddle point optimization so fairly
general problems where you can make
progress by
uh by reducing the size of your data set
and and where you can usefully use a
quantum computer without any any kind of
weird data assumptions
um so let me let me be a little more
concrete about the type of problem i
want to solve
so um
one example of such a problem is maximum
likelihood estimation or you could also
say maximum a past jewelry estimation if
there's a prior
you have a set of models y and a data
set x
and you assume that the data sets drawn
from a bunch of data points that are
that are independently sampled from some
distribution that's that's given by your
your models you want to find the most
likely y the most likely model y
that could generate that data set that
means maximizing the log likelihood
so the chance of seeing point x given y
is p of x given y
the log of that is f of x given y sort
of this measure of a score
of how good is uh y given
uh you know how well do x and y fit
together you want to sum that over your
whole data set because we have
this is log likelihood and maybe add a
term ry that represents
how much you prefer some models over
others even before you've seen any data
maybe because you have a prior
or because some models are are simpler
than others
um so this is a basic and
general problem pretty easy to relate to
to applications um how can the quantum
computer speed this up if you don't know
anything more about the structure of it
um so as a math equation
x and y appear almost symmetrically okay
one of them is a maps and one of them is
a sum
but they're you can get grover speed ups
for both of these
however uh x lives on a hard drive it's
a data set
we do not have superposition access to
it whereas
why for many classes of models is a
a synthetic data set it's like the truth
table of a function um
it's something that we can easily get
superposition access to
for example if it's a clustering problem
y could be the set of all possible
clusterings and so
you would enumerate all the possible
centers
and weights or covariance matrices of
these clusters
that's something that you don't need to
explicitly list all of them you have an
implicit list of you can you can get
functional access to it
and so in our model of a classical
computer controlling a quantum computer
um you can if you wanted to do a grover
uh you know see what your grover speed
up was then your
outer loop would be the search over y
you could get a square root speed up
there
but your inner loop you'd still have to
step over the whole data set
right the inner loop where you sum over
x you would not be able to get a
meaningful speed up
um and this is
uh and you can imagine doing better than
grover by the way i'm gonna use grover
for concreteness because it's always
bothered me
that i don't know how to use grover to
solve these simple optimization problems
um there are possibly better
optimization algorithms than grovers you
know like maybe adiabatic will turn out
to be really great or
you know qaoa or something else that is
whatever you use
that's gonna improve the dependence on
why if you're lucky maybe it'll improve
it exponentially
who knows but the more it improves
dependence on y
and leaves x untouched um
then you know the almost the more
unsatisfactory becomes because you're
still
your runtime is still dominated by this
this large data set
so one question to get these algorithms
to work well is can we reduce the
dependence
on the size of x um
before i talk about how to do this any
question about the model about the
problems that we're trying to solve
um uh yeah so i i see a question in the
chat which let me try to rephrase a
little bit
uh you know it sort of says well these
y's are actually usually very structured
it says
they're continuous but there's there's
also structure in them
and so just just getting even if you
discretize getting square root of y may
not be enough but
maybe that you have some effective
dimensions so do you do you have
something to
say about that good right um
yeah very good question so let's suppose
that
um your set y
is um let's say the weights of some
neural network
of course that's continuous and you
might try to solve that with gradient
descent
and when you do that you find that you
end in a local minimum
so one thing that you might do uh on a
classical computer is just restart
a gazillion times and what this amounts
to is searching over your local minima
um and so whenever you're doing
something where you
pick a random starting point and then
you run some short algorithm like you
you do a brief gradient descent and then
you evaluate
um and you're just trying that over and
over and over again that is
amenable to grover so what you could do
then if you're not
literally grovering over every single
weight in the neural network because
that would be wasteful you you actually
grading sets a good algorithm
but you're growing over starting points
for gradient descent and then running a
short gradient descent
so that's one answer um another answer
is
um you know grover's not the the only
algorithm there's this um
beautiful algorithm that came out of
maryland for um escaping saddle points
on a
on a quantum computer um and uh
you know that that gives you another
sort of tool and your optimization tool
toolkit for for optimizing over
non-convex functions so there could be
things that you do that are
that are that are better than grover
yeah you can also search over the hyper
parameters i opened up the chat window
so i
can see these things now and
kind of whatever you're doing like
whatever you're doing to speed up your
search
um if the inner loop has it dependent on
the full data set
that is gonna that is going to kill you
no matter what right so
you can imagine i'm just kind of saying
grover to
like to give you something concrete to
sink your teeth into but
definitely there depending on the
problem there may be many many better
ways to do it and actually
later on i'll show you an example of
something where you can um
i'll come back to this where you can
definitely do better than grover
basically
grover is like a square root of a brute
force search and
there are square root speed ups have
better algorithms out there as well so
sometimes
we have a square root speed up of what's
possibly the best classical algorithm
um and you know grover certainly is not
that um
so um
uh yeah so so so we'll see that example
but basically i wanted i'm saying grover
to give you something to
sink your teeth into to so you can
appreciate the data issues
that arise really in any of these
optimization algorithms
um another question was about what is
the relation between x
and y um
well you know what at one level they're
decoupled like you have a space of
models you're searching over like
all possible clusterings and then x is
just your set of data points
so um basically why are the possible
models and then once you know
once and you're assuming that there
exists some model and then
the data set x is sampled from the the
distribution corresponding to that model
now you know maybe in practice the more
data you have
uh the richer the family of models you
can search over so there may be some
kind of
uh implicit dependence like that but in
general the
there there doesn't have to be a direct
relation between them
um
yeah thanks for the questions um aaron
henry asks henry you and asks if the
search over the data set is in the inner
loop and the outer loop is searching
over y in superposition
doesn't that mean x is being accessed
and superpositioned
uh yeah so
what's happening to x is something like
this except what we're really doing
is we're saying um conditioned on
y add f of
x comma y to your running total of the
log likelihood
and then iterate that over all values of
x
so when i say accessing x in
superposition
um what we're not doing is we're never
making a superposition
of queries to different values of x
right so different data points were
never querying at the same time
the the data point the the the x that
we're querying is a classical variable
you know the hard drive is like it's on
that platter and the
the head of the hard drive is pointing
to one record on the platter
and that is a classical thing that we're
querying
and then we're sequentially stepping
through all the values of x
hope that answers that question
good
yes it's uh
okay so um
so what can we do you know having to
wait
to go through every record on the hard
drive
um while my quantum computer is
decohering makes me very sad so i don't
wanna
i don't wanna spend all that time doing
that and the inner loop of my quantum
algorithm
it's also you know it's the quantum
computer
it's like having your quantum computer
spend time doing arithmetic right
like doing like a 32-bit multiply
on a quantum computer is very sad to do
because there's no advantage there right
the advantage comes from other parts of
the circuit
so you want to spend as little time as
possible on the stuff that doesn't
is not bringing you quantum advantage so
one thing you can do
is approximate your big data set by a
small data set
that's called this idea came from the
computational geometry and this has
spread to machine learning
um it's called taking a core set um
and i've illustrated this for the
example of
of clustering um but it's uh
the corsets exist for for many different
problems and the idea is that you
approximate your original data set x
with a subset
x prime um
or i should maybe written x prime comma
w because i also need a set of weights
that go
along with it um and we say x prime is a
core set
if uh for all models y
the true log likelihood on the left is
approximated
by the uh approximate log likelihood we
get from just looking at the core set
so that's just um looking at the
um just summing over the points in x
prime
and we have to add a weight i mean just
at one level there are
a lot more terms on the left hand side
than the right hand side so to get them
to be comparable
you'll need some weight but it's
actually a lot more interesting than
that
the weights should um one of the most
common ways to build a corset is via
important sampling where you assign
different weights to different points
based on uh basically how critical they
are to the model
so in a setting like this where you have
a big cluster and some small clusters
you um you don't want to choose
x prime by uniform sampling because then
you'll just miss the small clusters
so you want to boost the weight of the
boost
i'm sorry the probability of these small
clusters right so you want to make sure
that you
you you hit the small clusters uh just
as much as the big ones
but you don't want your model to get
confused about the relative importance
of those small clusters so you put in
the points from the small cluster you
put them in with high probability
and low weight whereas the points from
the big cluster
each point gets low probability and high
weight
and so the weight is meant to to balance
the probability of sampling these things
and that's a critical component of of
important sampling
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on that because this is really a
technique from classical machine
learning it's not
uh there's nothing particularly quantum
about it but this is
um yeah this is one of this one of the
standard ways of generating core sets
via uh this tool called important
sampling
and so this gives rise to a um
a hybrid algorithm for machine learning
you have your data set x
you feed it into a classical computer
you get out
a course at x prime feed that into your
quantum computer and you get out of
model y
so a little more concretely how do you
get your core set
so you know i said you can you can do it
via this
technique called important sampling uh
where you weight the things in the big
clusters
differently than things in the small
clusters but how do you know what's in
the big clusters you haven't solved the
problem right so there's a bit of a
chicken and egg
so one way you can do this and we'll see
a few different
um a few different answers to this
one way you can do it is uh
you first get a crude approximation so
the classical computer gets a very crude
approximation y prime
for clustering such an approximation
might be one of these by factor
approximations
where not only it's not a very accurate
clustering but also you use maybe
10 times as many cluster centers as you
ultimately want to get
and this can be used to construct
important sampling weights
yes you can that's right that's how you
can get y prime is by classical
em algorithm is a way of doing this so
the point is it can be a fairly
lousy approximation the quality of y
prime will not
affect the quality of the final
approximation it will only affect the
run time to get there it'll only affect
the size of the core set
so use that to construct important
sampling weights use that to construct
x prime then you feed that to your
quantity computer
use grover or whatever your favorite
quantum optimization algorithm is
to find the model y and now
you've cut down the cost of the inner
loop to be only dependent on the size of
x prime so if x prime is much smaller
than x um then you can get nearly the
full grover speed up or whatever your
optimization algorithm is
the inner loop no longer becomes a
dominant cost a dominant part of the
runtime
and for algorithms like clustering this
is a case where we know
good core sets exist so this this whole
pipeline where you choose an approximate
answer quickly
use that to make important sampling
weights draw a small core set etc
uh this is something that's proven to
work for uh
many many forms of clustering and this
is a
um a promising area for quantum speed up
because
the last step is where you brute force
over clusterings of your core set
and this again doing a brute force
search over a combinatorial space
uh is something where grover's algorithm
works without any of these data issues
um and that becomes something where uh
a quantum computer can um
can can give a can speed up relative to
the best known
classical algorithm for a for a big data
problem
any questions about this i'm i'm skating
over the details of important sampling
but i can
i can get more into that if people have
questions about it
good so um so this algorithm
you know it's good as far as it goes in
that it it speeds up
a fairly natural problem but
as a quantum algorithm designer i find
it a little unsatisfactory because
you know the classical computer acquires
the data
processes it uh digests it
and gives a small you know
representative subset to the quantum
computer
it's like what the mama bird does she
finds the worm brings it back
chews it up regurgitates it the quantum
computer is just like this baby
in the nest you know can we do something
a little
a little more glorious for the quantum
computer
um what about some kind of interactive
protocol where the quantum computer
sends requests back and says well i'd
like a worm with more calcium please or
you know maybe dropping the analogy
can you return me a record that tells
you know of this nature instead of just
instead of your predefined important
sampling weights
uh can you do something useful there and
so here's a there are many many ways of
doing this
um one proposal due to campbell and
broderick
um i'll describe and there's also this
review paper with with
other examples of adaptive core sets it
describes a um oh right so this actually
answers the question that just came up
is there no quantum constructing x
prime well not for the first one i gave
you uh
but for the the subsequent algorithms
the quantum computer will play a role in
constructing x
prime um so
the um
right so the next problem i want to
consider is like
maximum likelihood maximum likelihood we
want to choose the best model
for bayesian inference what we want to
do um
is we start with a prior pi zero of y
um we still have our log likelihoods and
our data set
and that yields a posterior distribution
pi of y given by this formula and we
want a sample from this
posterior and so this gives us
not just the point estimate of what is
the best model but some measure of
a confidence interval around it you know
like how um
like error bars basically so one
fairly general way of using a quantum
computer to get an adaptive core set
is the classical computer in round t
sends a core set of size t to the
quantum computer think of t
is pretty small way smaller than the
full data set the quantity computer
samples from uh the posterior
distribution
corresponding to this core set
so it's uh you know not from the true
distribution
the quantum meter doesn't have time to
look at all the data it just has time to
look at this small core set
and they can sample from the posterior
here
now how does it do this here is a case
where
instead of doing the square root speed
up of brute force search we can do the
square root speed up of something a lot
smarter
for example one way that a classical
computer might do
this sorry if a classical computer do
the sample you might do it via simulator
to kneeling
where you gradually you start from a
high temperature distribution and
gradually
reduce the temperature and this is
something where
this is a relatively good algorithm and
a quantum computer can get a square root
speed up of this
um i mean modulo a few
i should say a nearly square root speed
up um
i can get into details if you want but
uh
there we're we're closer to square root
speeding up the the best algorithm
um and uh
yes exactly so so pi zero you can view
pi zero either as the prior
or pi zero is what you get when there's
no data right sort of it's consistent
with this pi sub t
um and then so the quantum computer
draws a sample
y sub t and sends it back and then the
class of computer has access to
the corset so far with the weight
as well as all of the y1 through yt's
and it can use that
to update its corset to choose the next
points to add
um based on the y1 through yt that it's
seen so far
um and basically what it can do is it
can do
it can say let me try to find a point
that is not
well fit by the models i've seen so far
so instead of just choosing according to
the pre-existing important sampling
weights
say the models from the quantum computer
what have they missed whatever those are
we should focus on that part of the data
set um
and uh campbell and broderick have a
scheme for doing this
since it's essentially classical i won't
go into the details but this gives you
kind of the idea of a framework of how
you can
um uh adaptively build up a core set
where you're you're making use of the
output of the quantum computer in the in
the process of doing this
um and then
yeah so i'm going to move on to a a more
concrete example this was maybe a little
bit general i'm going to move on to a
more concrete example where we can you
know
have an algorithm i fully described with
a provable performance
this algorithm is sort of a heuristic
like it's a it's a plausible algorithm
campbell and product
have a concrete proposal which i just
won't go into right now um
but it doesn't have a approvable
convergence time or rather
it does but it depends on parameters
that are hard to estimate like the
adiabatic algorithm depends on the gap
that's good to know but what's the gap
right and so
this is something where i think it's a
promising heuristic to try
uh but it's hard to say in general how
well it works
any any questions before i go on to a
concrete
uh instantiation
okay so let me talk about a problem
where
i can describe how everything works in
more detail
but i have to specialize a little bit so
i'm going to specialize
to um a problem called saddle point
optimization
and i'm going to change a little bit my
setup
so instead of x being my data set i want
x to be the convex
hull of all of my data points so here
are my data points that convex means the
smallest convex set
containing them and why my space of
models
i'm going to make that convex as well if
you're familiar with boosting
that's a little bit like what happens in
boosting where you're allowed to
output not just a model but some some
convex mixture of
of models um and
my objective function f i want to be
linear
in in x and y and if i make these
assumptions
then i have this minimax theorem well
okay i'm sorry the thing i want to do is
i want to
maximize over y and then minimize over x
and
if i make that i'm sorry uh arm can you
can you go over the
problem statement again there's a little
bit on yeah
the the problem statement is compute the
max over y
of the minimum of x of f of x y right
and x and y
are again sorry i missed x
is the convex hull of a bunch of data
points that you're given
and why you can think of as the convex
hall of m models that you're given or
you could just think of it as a set of
probability distributions over
m items
so um
let me let me make this a little bit
more concrete
um so one example of this is a zero
sum game i mean the way i've written it
it really sounds a lot like a zero sum
game where there's
an x player and the x player's strategy
are described by records on a hard drive
and the y player
and the y player strategy is given by
something you have superposition access
to so
for example suppose i have some you know
enormous data set of
um you know possibly fraudulent credit
card transactions that would be x
and then y would be a set of strategies
for identifying fraud
that you know maybe these strategies are
described by some parameters so i have
superposition access to them
um something like that so a zero-sum
game where
on one side there's data and the other
side there's sort of an implicit data
set something i have superposition
access to
um another way of viewing this is linear
programming
so x so i want to find a point in the
probability simplex
an x is set of linear constraints every
point x describes some
half space that cuts down the space
it's a little bit like um maximum
likelihood estimation you can see
instead of for maximum likelihood
estimation i'm doing a max over y
followed by a sum over x this is a
minimum over x
so you could imagine a clustering
problem where instead of caring about
the average error for any point i care
about the worst case error
so you know think about some kind of
coverage problem where i want to make
sure that no customer has like
service below some some quality uh it's
also related to
if you know svm this is like svm using
the l1 norm instead of l2
um so this is something that's very
amenable to these hybrid algorithms
uh following um you notice the theme
here there's some classical algorithm
that we can
easily adapt to this setting and so
there's a an algorithm from 25 years ago
called a fictitious play which i'll
illustrate
in the context of rock paper scissors so
you want to converge to a nosh
equilibrium for rock paper scissors
um the simplest thing which doesn't work
is just have one player pick a strategy
like scissors
and the other one does the best response
so then the other player would do rock
and then you respond with paper then you
respond with scissors and and you can
see it just kind of cycle forever
but if you put in a little bit of noise
it will converge
rapidly so here's how that goes here's
your payoff matrix
and i've set it up so this is the payoff
for the y player
uh so the y player wants to maximize it
and the x player wants to minimize
it and the way it goes is you'll choose
the x player will choose x1 arbitrarily
let's say rock
that will induce some vector of payoffs
for the y
player the y player will
sample a y one in a way that is biased
towards
larger payoffs but not deterministically
picking the highest one so paper is more
likely
scissors is less likely let's say that
y1 happens to be paper the more likely
one
then we go to the x player that induces
a column of payoff for x
x now bias it towards the lower numbers
and let's so
you know scissors is most likely let's
say that x happens to choose paper
because that happens with some
probability now
the y player responds to the sum of
everything that x has done so far
so you see if epsilon is small at first
the players are bouncing around at
random
but the probability of choosing some bad
strategy starts to decrease
exponentially with the number of rounds
and so it converges pretty rapidly
at least rapidly in terms of the number
of strategies so they prove that the
number of rounds you need
scales like the size of
the um the size of the strategy space
divided by um
uh divided by epsilon squared so the
performance with error is not so good
the performance in terms of size of the
strategy spaces
is very good and this is a natural
hybrid algorithm because if t is not too
large
there are t rounds of alternation and
what do the classical and quantum
computers have to do the classical
computer
has to sweep through the data set and
for each data point
it has to to calculate you know the sum
of the t
things that's returned from the quantum
computer so it has to do an order t
calculation for every data point which
is not too bad if t is not too big
likewise let's say the quantum computer
was going to use grover to search over
its strategies
you were already willing to do grover
once and now what you have to do is you
have to do grover t
times with an order t calculation in the
inner loop
so if t is not too bad this is not
much more than just the minimum you were
willing to do to you know to run grover
once with a simple inner loop
um so this is a
you know a fairly concrete way of an
example of an interactive classical
quantum algorithm
uh to to solve a problem using a large
data set
uh any questions before i before i go on
okay so i prepared a few other things
but i should probably go through them
quickly
um to not um not take up too much time
uh i want to mention you know when
people say variational algorithms
sorry when people say um
uh yeah okay so
a few questions about this last one t
scales with the size of the matrix so i
assume it's not so big
well it scales there's a log here scales
logarithmically the size of a matrix so
um so you know i consider log to be not
too big compared to
uh to other things in the problem and
another question is
the output strategy is a superposition
uh the output strategy is a mixture yeah
good question the output strategy is a
is a mixture of all of the things that
have been output to date
so you know this produces a sequence of
outputs x1 x2 dot through x sub t
the final strategy is the uniform
mixture of x1 through st
um okay so when people think about
hybrid algorithms
they're often thinking about variational
algorithms um
and these look like um
you have some variational onstops and
that looks like you start with some
state psi
zero you apply a sequence of uh
given by some parameters t1 through tp
um one example is qaoa so you maybe
start with uh
all uh many copies of the plus state
sorry that should be psi
zero with many copies of the plus state
and then you apply alternatingly either
the sigma x hamiltonian
or your the function you want to
optimize along the diagonal
or another thing you might do with the
the variational quantum
eigensolver where you're trying to
minimize some hamiltonian
and you alternate uh you know different
terms in the hamiltonian
these are all um different
variational algorithms that you might
run on a quantum computer and the way
they generally work
is you have a classical outer loop that
searches over these parameters
and then the quantum computer is used to
uh to estimate the expectation value
basically how good
how good is your approximation um
and uh one thing that's appealing about
this is it
you can this is this yields something
interesting even for a very simple
quantum computer so you don't
um you know you run the quantum computer
basically as long as you can get away
with
um and that defines the quality of your
onset and then and then you search over
that
um so it's easy for small p p is the
number of parameters here
um and it's exact as as the number of
parameters goes to infinity
because it includes things like
adiabatic evolution that will always
give the right answer of course
that might take exponential time uh
but you know at least in principle this
family
uh you know it's not going to to
saturate at some small value you know
that
it has at least the potential of doing
well um
but at this point it's so general that
you know maybe you don't have enough
guidance to do
to uh to solve it so
one question is should you be using a
zeroth order method
where the quantum computer's job is to
estimate the energy
or a first order method where the
quantity job is to estimate the gradient
uh or maybe a second order method where
the we are evaluating things about the
matrix of second derivatives
um and i think i don't have time to
really get into this
um it turns out a quantum computer can
estimate gradients efficiently
the cost is barely more than estimating
the energy
um and uh in some cases you have some
rigorous performance guarantees which i
think i'm gonna
i'm gonna skip um and it turns out that
there's a very very simple example
where these gradient algorithms do
better than
ones that just measure the energy it's
it's just the out the hamiltonian is
just the sum
of single cubit terms so super simple
nothing fancy going on
you wouldn't even think that these n
qubits even interact
but they do interact kind of via the
outer loop of gradient descent
and it turns out uh in that case that
um that we can prove that that first
order
that gradient algorithms do better than
uh
than just direct energy measurements uh
and i think there's
for this out for this case there's no
advantage in going on to second order
algorithms
but i think that's an interesting thing
to look at in in future work
um second order algorithms where you
look at the hessian
have not been popular for classical
gradient descent
because it's too expensive to write down
the whole hessian
um but here i think there's uh
the trade-offs are a little bit
different we're willing to have the
classical computers sweat
a little bit more to save the quantum
computer time and so
one thing that i want to look at in the
future and encourage people in the
audience to do as well is think about
ways that
that second order methods could could
further improve these quantum
variational algorithms
um now you know these performance
guarantees which i sort of
went through quickly or you know didn't
really explain at all
uh are all in the neighborhood of a
local minimum
but the problem with these variational
methods with anything with gradient
descent
is how do you even reach a local minimum
uh
or sorry a good local minimum i didn't
say this very well how do you find a
good local minimum in the first place
um and one
challenge is that if you just do random
initialization
uh you get something called the the
baron plateau
problem and this is actually kind of a
beautiful plateau but you know imagine a
very very
flat plateau that is sort of what the
solution landscape looks like
uh and uh that makes it very hard to
figure out which way to go in
so um more concretely let's say that
f is the thing you want to evaluate it's
you know the expectation value of your
hamiltonian
the gradient of f goes down
exponentially
with the depth of your circuit if you do
a random initialization
now you know one one answer to this is
well random initializations are just a
bad idea
you know what we do with our computers
is usually not pound on the keyboard at
random usually there's some structure to
it
uh and misha's lukens group has had a
lot of progress
with uh initialization strategies that
are inspired by adiabatics but but go
beyond it
and uh my group is is looking at some
some ideas related to this which
um they're not quite far enough along to
present but
but hopefully soon we'll have something
to say about it um
but it's uh it is a challenge for these
algorithms is finding a good
initialization
and one further thing this is another so
uh unpublished work from eric anchored
to the student in my group
if you zoom in on the barren plateau
it's actually not flat
um it's actually full of teeny teeny
teeny tiny little bumps
uh and he has a heuristic argument for
this sort of in a toy model and then
conjectures that they should hold more
generally um
but in so the the the
the scope of his claim we don't know
kind of how widely it applies
but in many so but wherever his his
heuristic model applies
there should be exponentially many local
minima
with uh that are very bad local minima
that they are basically
not much better than doing something at
random so not only is this plateau
kind of very flat uh with exponentially
small gradients
it has many many of these little little
bumps in it um
and you know numerically here's an
example of what the transverse field
icing model looks like
when you just sort of jump in at a
random point
you really really do see lots of little
bumps um
so this does not mean that the these
algorithms are doomed
it just means that uh there's more work
to be done in getting a good
initialization so
um and i think it's a little bit like
the situation with deep neural networks
right if you
there's not gonna be any general purpose
theorem that we can always find a good
answer for them
nevertheless there are many strategies
which empirically cause them to work
well and
and there are many ways that we can find
regularities and and fi
and and get them to work well in
practice so these difficulties are not
the end of the road um similarly for
this recent paper by mp hardness it's
not the end of the road it's just uh
it's sort of the first step towards
towards finding better algorithms
so uh sorry may i ask a question um
so so you um you spoke a little bit
about where the algorithm
would run into difficulties do you have
any heuristic
or do you have any picture of
uh where the algorithm might work well
no not provably well but you know if you
wanted to
say if you wanted to look for places
where where variational methods or qaoa
actually works better than classical
algorithms yeah where would you look or
where would you
have a feeling that they do or something
yeah
like they do right like let's say you
you just have your system of 100 cubits
you want to try this thing
you know you want to hear about np
hardness you say okay what do i try give
me you know give me an idea i'll try it
i'll see if it works
um and so you'd like some guidance about
uh something that's maybe guaranteed to
work in some regime
and then you try it somewhere else and
one thing that you know does
one thing that's very appealing is to
start with an adiabatic path
because adiabatic
the adiabatic algorithm does work if you
take exponential time
and there is um it often does okay if
you use less time
um there's the next slightly smarter
thing you might do there's something
called the shortcut to adiabaticity
there's an enormous literature on
various strategies of doing better
um and that might also be a starting
point you might use
for example you might use adiabatic
where you run at different speeds at
different times
um there's one thing that i've been
looking at
um which you know when i
when i said i would give this talk i was
kind of hoping i'd be further along in
terms of results but i i don't have a
slide on it yet
but let me try to describe it um
so one case
which i which is so one thing you might
do for a general problem
is you might say let me engage in
wishful thinking
and hope that my my
problem secretly has n
qubits of decoupled degrees of freedom
so that's
crazy i have some big interacting system
but you know maybe
it has a description in terms of quasi
particles
and these quasi particles are weakly
interacting
and sometimes this is true so you have
exactly solvable models like the
transverse field icing model
which really do just map onto n
decoupled qubits
and if you do adiabatic evolution there
it corresponds to
adiabatically evolving each of these
n-qubits separately
but if you know you're dealing with
qubits you can do something a lot
smarter
you can do something like the
cubitization technique that people have
used for hamiltonian simulation
and you can do some pulse sequence uh
that will
you know that will do a better job that
that might even be um
and you know you can say if i have these
many degrees of freedom
maybe i'll do something that if their
parameters are in some range
i will do a good job on and if there's
some other range i i don't have any
guarantee
uh and so basically you can do things
that are sort of guided by what would
work well
for a single human hamiltonian and you
can hope that that works well for your
your general system um so i think that's
one
one set of strategies you can try um and
then the other another one is is getting
guidance from
um one of the things that goes slightly
beyond adiabatic
is in adiabatic evolution we often try
to stay in the ground state
but they're we're starting to understand
that if you go too quickly and you jump
into the first excited state
that can sometimes help you uh which is
uh
that's part of this is described in this
literature on shortcuts to idioticity
and so um that's something that
um you know that
indirectly you can also try with these
um
with these kinds of methods um
and finally um
yeah maybe it would take a long time to
you know one
there's a paper i can't remember who
wrote this by part of the google team
um and
they argue also in favor of um
basically one further idea that you can
do is suppose you want to solve qaoa so
you want to solve a classical
optimization problem
it might be better to still along the
way try to optimize
for some kind of quantum objective
function where you have a hamiltonian
with sigma x terms in it
and the reason for this is if you just
try to optimize a classical objective
function
then there'll be no control on the
phases of your wave function
and so your optimizer might end up
having your phases vary
in crazy ways and so putting in a little
bit of a regular
putting in these sigma x terms might act
a little bit like a regularizer
and try to prevent the the phases from
varying in too wild of a way
so anyway those are a few different
ideas and they're uh they're somewhat
disjoint
um and uh
yeah it's um
i i don't have any one clean answer
probably because i don't know and
probably because probably such a thing
that doesn't exist
but yeah it's a it's a great question
and uh you know
a very important area of future work
i should probably wrap up right we're 65
minutes into
into things um
so let me say that my saddle point
algorithm is secretly a form of gradient
descent um
and i'm just not going to explain how
but it's something called
stochastic l1 norm mirror descent so
turns out that these the different
halves of my talker are maybe not so
disconnected after all
uh i'll mention something i didn't have
time to get into but
uh hybrid algorithms also could play an
important role in quantum simulations
um there's a big line of research called
error mitigation
um which is basically you simulate some
parameters and you extrapolate to other
ones
that's a one type of hybrid algorithm
another one is there are these
randomized trotter methods
where people have been choosing the
terms in the decomposition
maybe just according to the strength of
the term but there's room for making
these adaptive as well for
uh choosing them using an important
sampling which would actually look at
the quantum statement
involved another way of linking
classical and quantum is to do a quantum
simulation
where you use quantum monte carlo for
some degrees of freedom and use a
quantum computer to test their
contraction for for other degrees of
freedom these are
in each idea i think i would would take
quite some time to explain but uh those
are brief sketches of things you might
do in a hybrid way
uh and so yeah let me wrap up by by
talking about
um uh one more form of hybrid
computation after kasparov lost to
deep blue he um he didn't come up with
the idea but he helped popularize the
idea of
of centaur chess where there's a human
and a computer together
um and this example also illustrates the
difficulty of these algorithms because
there was a period when hybrid when
centaur teams
had ratings that were higher than the
best computers
um and that period has unfortunately
ended
and now humans do not add any value to
chess playing algorithms other than you
know
plugging the computer um and so
i hope that there will be a a long and
fruitful area
when both quantum and classical
computers will be integral
to the success of some algorithm and
uh i hope maybe some people in the
audience will come up with new ways of
doing this
you know thank you for your attention
great thank you thanks
uh thanks uh thanks aaron so
a wonderful talk so let's um you know if
there are any questions
yeah uh lynn lynn had a question earlier
if you want to unmute
that i think got missed um
it was oh hey
eric uh thanks for the very nice talk
yeah i was basically asking
that you argued about the second order
methods
yeah so definitely make the costco
computers sweat
but as far as i know they will make
quantum computer sweat as well quite a
bit
uh yeah so any comments
right um well this is a an idea for
future work so i have not gotten it to
work myself but let me tell you my
thoughts first of all there are two ways
of making the quantum computer sweat
there's
running it for longer time and then
there's repeating it more often
and for our current quantum computers
there's just a hard limit to the first
one and
you know maybe running it more often is
is painful but doable but running for
more time is just
simply impossible if our noise rate
can't be brought down
so it might be acceptable to run a
quantum computer a ton of times
uh second i think there
is room for using the classical computer
to do things that would be way too
expensive
for a normal grading descent thing like
i could use a classical computer to
solve a semi-definite program
to find an estimate of the hessian
based on a few measurements of the
quantum computer right
so you know think of the
the classical computer should be like
waiting hand on foot on the quantum
computer any data that comes out of the
quantum computer
the classical computer should work super
hard to interpret and so
if i have to solve a semi-definite
program every single time the quantum
computer finishes a run
you know that's probably still a good
use of my resources
um so um
yeah you have to control your mode the
color error you have to run a lot
right so to make that hessian useful
well what i'm thinking is not a
uh yeah so what i what i don't know is
if you could mitigate that
by um
by running the possible computer for
longer so if you think about like
l b f g s you're making gradient
measurements
and you're using this to infer some like
really lousy approximation of the
hessian
right so you're not making a ton of
gradient measurements
you're not making nearly enough to
fulfill full hessian
so that's kind of what i'm thinking of
here i'd like you to make a few
gradient measurements
uh you know
approximate it use some kind of seminar
program or other convex program
to get some uh you know some suitably
regularized thing
but you know you're absolutely right we
we have to do something smarter than
just running a bunch of times and trying
to estimate every single entry of the
hessian because
um that you know that that might
be really too many repetitions okay
thanks
okay yeah so i see there's both a chat
window and a q a window
um let me go through
yeah or just how should we do yeah no
plea please please do and
i i should just say that um i also
posted
on chat or or the messages uh
the gather town link for people who want
to
you know who want to go there
as this discussion comes to an end right
yeah i guess once we close the zoom
window then i'll show up at gather town
or something right
right right um
okay so um yeah let me go through the
chat first
um what's what i mean by transverse
field
icing model um icing model means that
there's
there's zv nearest neighbor zz
interactions transverse field means that
there also is a sigma x term
uh and just go to wikipedia for
transverse field ic model and i think
it'll explain it pretty well
um and for the two player games
no there's no quantum superposition at
the end of the algorithm
uh the strategy that you know at every
round
the classical computer is output x1 x2
through x sub t
right and the quadratic meter is output
y1 y2 through y sub t these are
classical strings that have been output
and so at the end of the day
the classical strategy is just the
average of x1 through xt
and the quantum strategy is the average
of y1 through yt so there's no
there's no superposition at the end and
the quantum computer for each run
it does some search and then you know
you assume that the thing is
fully decoded here you reset it you uh
you know
whatever vacuum out your lab whatever
and restart it
uh is there a limitation to qao in terms
of locality if they don't see the graph
that's not so good um
uh yes certainly that's that's
that's probably true um
but you know it doesn't take too long to
see the whole graph um
oh some people have answered these
questions already so um
[Music]
um okay so
um is the calculation of the gradient
itself done in a quantum way
so i kind of went through this too
quickly
um let me show you how to do it
but uh yeah so this was a point of our
paper
one way you can calculate the gradient
is the finite differences
right so then the quantity computer is
just estimating the value of the energy
and you just estimated it two nearby
points and you subtract
and that's going to give you your
gradient estimate
and some of the early works on
variational algorithms suggested that
this was a better way to go
because when you measure the energy
there are many commuting terms and you
can estimate you can measure them all at
once
and when you measure the gradient um you
cannot
they're um you just each one of the
quantum computer just estimates one term
in the gradient
um and so it was maybe a little
surprising that it's still you're still
better off doing this
and um i'm just going to leave up on the
screen what is the quantum circuit for
estimating the gradient
i i won't run through it but you know
there is a simple thing to do and
it basically is the same as the normal
algorithm requires one
extra cubit and in a few places you have
to do something
controlled so it's barely barely more
effort for the quantum computer
than estimate the energy um
for the bad local minima you know yes
maybe there may be some averaging method
to get around it
you know simulator kneeling um i'm not
saying this is a show stopper
um
and i you know many of the issues that
come up there are similar to the issues
that come up in neural networks so it's
not a uh
you know it's a well-studied problem
where we don't have a unique quantum
answer to we're
grappling with many of the same issues
um
and
okay i've um i think i've answered most
of the questions
anyone feel like i haven't answered
their question
or want to ask a new one
just to follow up on the question i
asked before
would you comment on i mean there have
been some papers
saying that qaoa for example the hybrid
quantum classic algorithm doesn't really
beat classical algorithms for things
like
max cut and saturn the you know other
combinatorial problems any
comments on that
um
well the one for um
yeah so those are um
yeah so there are two different issues
there are a few different no-gos that
have come up for qaoa
um and um
the ones there are two issues that come
up there's symmetry
and locality so there's a paper by um
bravi sergey bravi eugene tang
maybe robert kernig and one other person
um where they refer to symmetry as a
problem
um and there's
that one also talks about a limitation
by local
about locality i mean i think probably
the simpler one is
if you are if the depth of qa always too
low
then you can't even see the whole graph
right um so if you're running it for
less time than it takes for a signal to
get from one end
of the quad computer to the other one
how are you going to solve a problem
that depends on the whole thing um
and you know i think that's a valid
point but
you're running you'd be running qaoa in
such a limited
like if you're running for such a low
depth uh you probably wouldn't expect it
to do too well
um you know
uh
yeah so i think these no-go theorems are
are interesting but basically they apply
um they apply to a very restricted
version of
of the of
of these variational algorithms um
you know there's a sense in which
you know i think the thing about
variational algorithms is
there's a sense in which they're fully
general like suppose
i have any quantum algorithm to solve
max cut
and i that algorithm is a sequence of
gates
and i run it then you know what i can
always do is i can just say
well let me look at the gradient if i
mess around with each of these
individual gates
and let me just take a little step to
improve the
the objective function right so for any
algorithm that i start with
i can take some gradient steps to try to
improve it
and variational algorithms are so
general
that they include basically taking
any possible algorithm and taking
gradient steps to improve it
right so there's um
[Music]
you know there like it's almost vacuous
to talk about like great variational
algorithms in general
like really there are two steps there's
i need to find a good
starting guess like a good starting
heuristic and that can come from
uh adiabatic or shortcut to adiabaticity
or
or you know some other idea that might
exploit some structure of the problem
um and then i you know i iteratively
improve it via some
some sort of gradient descent uh and
the first step is fully general like i'm
already starting with like
my best possible guess of how to begin
and then
you know yeah why not improve it via
creating descent um
so you know there's a sense in which
like
we should absolutely be trying these
variational algorithms
but it doesn't favor like if you just
say
this is a variational algorithm like you
haven't really said very much
you know there's uh there's quite a lot
of room to narrow things down
um so it's uh you know on the other hand
it's it's very hard to like
say anything definite about them without
trying to make assumptions
so uh that's for why our grading descent
paper
you know we had to focus on like a very
simple problem in order to like
say something provable um
and uh i mean it's a little bit like
neural networks there right so neural
networks are
a touring complete model of computation
and uh and they're differentiable so
you you start off with some maybe
initial guess of how to tackle the
problem maybe your
your thing is informed by some intuition
about the structure like oh it's an
image
do a convolutional network um and then
you set it up so that you can take
derivatives
uh and so you can do gradient descent um
you know it's uh
it's so it's it's hard to say stuff in
complete generality
um instead of sort of like a a good
framework for thinking about algorithms
um but you know sometimes you have to
you have to get more concrete to say
more specific things
um can i ask a question more on the
first half of the talk
please yeah yeah so it seemed like the
main idea there
for the hybrid nature was you know you
really want to be smart about what
classical data you're using um so
in terms of either using important
sampling or finding a way to iteratively
uh do that update
i guess the question i have is is more
about the application because it seemed
like the problem was it was more along
the lines of
parameter estimation as like along that
line of uh
problem and i was wondering if you had
applications
in mind for um
like what you would use a quantum
computer to
like yeah um so
yeah so in the archive link um this the
second paper here
um i give i spell out a few examples um
the three algorithms so let me go
through each one um
i guess for the the non-adaptive core
sets
um i think
clustering was the main example i had in
mind um and
and clustering clustering is quite
general when you think of all the
possible metrics and so on
um the second one um i was thinking of
some sort of hard
bayesian inference problem so
you know you just have some gnarly model
and you have some data points and you
want to
you want to infer the you want to sample
from the the parameters i guess that's
what you said of parameter estimation
um and for the third problem
it's like that but you you have to have
some reason why you care about
um about minimax like you you have to
care about
why do you want to do a good job on all
of your data points and not just sort of
on
average like why is it unacceptable to
miss any one data point
and so i think for like security type
games where you're interested in
possible ways to hack into a system or
possible ways to commit credit card
fraud
uh where there's some sort of
adversarial element
you really want to make sure that you um
do an okay job on
all of the possible ways because an
attacker would just shift resources to
some undefended
approach um or if there's some sort of
coverage
problem like you know i'm doing a
vaccination campaign and i
there's no i don't want to miss any one
subgroup i want to i want to make sure
that i
i get decent coverage everywhere instead
of just sort of
uh you know on average doing well um
yeah does that does that answer yeah
those are the sort of applications i had
in mind is that yeah yeah
that's helpful i i guess i was just
wondering if um i mean the
obviously like you said the you know the
applications of those problems are quite
um broad i guess i was wondering if
there was any
intuition for why you know a quantum uh
computer would
would be better at doing those tests but
uh maybe that's
well i mean i think the like for
you know in in each of those tasks
there's some
point at which you're doing a brute
force search or
where you're doing similar to kneeling
um
and so i see okay at that point
you know that is your you have a
quadratic quantum speed up
um now
i wish you could get more than a
quadratic quantum speed up um
but uh yeah
right so so um can i ask you a different
uh funny question you know so
um well one could say that um
you know that we we um formulated
optimization problems because of you
know in
in the classical world in in terms of
uh you know what we want to do or what
processes
actually natural process processes
we think of as doing so um
when you think about variational
algorithms um
is there is there a different kind of uh
problem you know it is a different kind
of objective function we should be
thinking about
um
you mean like other than like a a
classical
like other than the one that you would
want for a classical optimization
algorithm
yeah yeah so you know is is there
you know if you were thinking from
scratch without without any buyers you
know and we were saying look uh
you know as you're saying well look
what's a variational algorithm you sort
of look at
what the quantum world can do you know
you think about well
you know there's a adiabatic algorithm
there's this there's that right so you
you say well what's natural to do in the
in the quantum world now let's add you
know
let's sort of uh take some tunable
parameters out there and then let's tune
them
in the using a classical computer
right so you definitely need an
objective function
right but is are you are you
are you sort of led to an objective
function
almost uh inevitably or is that
is that uh you know is that our
classical
sort of lens you know glasses uh looking
through this
oh i see i see what you're saying um
yeah you're saying could you have a do
you have a goal that's not
uh not summarized in terms of a single
objective function
yeah um
you know like sometimes you want to
instead of solving a problem you want to
do some sampling problem
for example sorry for example yeah um
[Music]
i
i mean maybe you have something in mind
that
but for me i mean i think like the
the you know the quantum computer that's
kind of why i started with this thing
about the input models
like at the end of the day the quantum
computer is going to solve the same
problem that the classical computer is
going to solve
but faster like there's no
it's hard to you know unless there's
some
unless you're talking about some kind of
communication model or
uh you know where once there's multiple
players and you can talk about privacy
and all kinds of uh
of other things can come into it but if
you're just gonna
if you know if you just have a computer
on your desk and you're putting in some
input and getting some output
um i i can't imagine just like
categorically how the like what is
inside your computer would change
your your goals of what you want to
compute like if you wanted to compute
some random sampling problem
you might have want to do that with your
classical computer already right
uh but maybe i'm just you know could be
a failure of imagination by me but
uh how about uh
tsp is hard and be hard
what sorry what about what is hard
modeling salesman problem
has ended hard
maybe the quantum computer can do better
not only faster just
yeah i mean like you could say um can
you improve the approximation quality
right so not just uh but
uh maybe through the impossible
now do we that was a gist of the
question
can you can you and enhance your horizon
of problems i mean the point is
what anything that quantum computer can
do unless you're talking about
multi-party where you could really get
into privacy or security or
you know compression whatever
but if just one computer on your desk
that you feed an input to
and you get a classical input to
classical output
because a classical computer can
simulate that
with at most an exponential slowdown
right
definitely exponential slowdown and you
know in a lot of cases better than
exponential
um then whatever possible quantumly is
also possible classically
so at some level we're always talking
about a speed up
right the question is just how much how
much of a speed up
um you know
it's like uh
okay that's good enough great
achievement you know it's like
um know if a student says will you give
me an a if i give you
a million dollars and i say oh you know
we could
talk about that and they say well give
me an if if i give you ten dollars
come on what kind of you know person you
think i am
then they say well we already
established that the question is just
what is the price
with the advantage of the quantum
computer it's at some level
it can only be speed it's just a
question of like how much of the speed
up
i don't that was the right analogy for
that
that's a nice one
all right should we get cookies and
gather that town
yeah i think we should we should do that
let's uh let me
end the recording and uh